ان نتوجه الان الى مدير مكتب الجزيره في
رام الله وليد العمري مرحبا وليد ما الذي
توفر من معلومات حتى اللحظه عن هذه
العمليه التي قامت بها القوه الاسرائيليه
الخاصه في
جنين هذه عمليه اغتيال مباشره نفذتها قوه
من الكوماندوز الاسرائيلي الذين تخفوا بزي
اطباء وممرضين ونساء ورجال عاديين نحو ع
تسللوا الى داخل مستشفى سينا في الضحي
الغربيه من مدينه جنين والقريب من منطقه
مخيم جنين ثم صعدوا الى الطابق الثالث حيث
كان يمكث الفلسطينيون الثلاثه وهم اثنان
من كتيبه الجنين من سرايا القدس والثالث
من كتائب عز الدين القسام التابعه لحركه
حماس وقاموا باغتيال داخل فراشهم فراش
المرض في المستشفى وهم شقيقان وايضا شخص
ثالث عمل يه الاغتيال نفذتها هذه القوه
المتستر في بزي مدني كما قلت زي النساء
وزي اطباء وزي ممرضين وكذلك اناس عاديين
ومن ثم انسحبت من المنطقه هي من قوات
الكوماندوز
الاسرائيليه ويبدو انها من قوات الشباك
تحديدا الجهاز الامن العام دخلت واقتحمت
هذا المستشفى الذي طالما تعرض لعملي اطلاق
نار وقبل ذلك كان قد قتل فيه اطباء
وممرضين عندما اطلقت النيران عليه في
الماضي لكن هذه المره ما جرى فجر هذا
اليوم ان هذه القوه تسللت الى داخله وهي
تقدر بنحو عشره من جنود الاحتلال متسترين
بالزي المدني وقاموا باغتيال الفلسطينيين
الثلاثه في قلب المستشفى ومن ثم انسحبوا
من المكان خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره
باغتيال الفلسطينيه الثلاثه يرتفع عد
الذين اغتالهم وقتلهم جنود الاحتلال الى
ثمانيه وبذلك يصبح مجمل من قتلهم جنود
الاحتلال والمستوطنون منذ بدايه الحرب على
غزه التي تدخل يومها ال6 ع اليوم منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي الى
381 شهيدا فلسطينيا ومن بين هؤلاء 62
شهيدا فلسطينيا سقطوا منذ بدايه العام
الحالي وهذا مؤشر شر على ان عمليات القتل
التي يصلها جيش الاحتلال في تصاعد داخل
الضفه الغربيه التي تشهدوا كل ليله وفجر
كل يوم عمليات اقتحام ومداهم متواصله وقد
شنت فيها حملات اعتقال منذ
بدايه منذ بدايه الحرب تتزايد وتتصاعد
ليليا تقريبا وارتفع العدد خلالها الى
اكثر من
66 500 فلسطيني تعرضوا لحملات الاعتقال
خلال هذه الفتره لكن ما جرى في جنين حاليا
هي عمليه
اغتيال تجاوز للمحرمات اقتحام مستشفى
والدخول وترويع الموجودين فيه سواء كانوا
من المرضى او من الاطباء ومن ثم المغادره
ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه مما تقوم به
قوات الاحتلال وكذلك المستوطنون مؤشر على
ان الحرب التي بداتها اسرائيل في قطاع غزه
في السابع من اكتوبر هي لا تستهدف حركه
حماس وحسب وانما تستهدف الكل الفلسطيني
وما يجري في الضفه الغربيه يؤكد على ذلك
وعلى استمرار هذه العمليات اقتحام كما قلت
خلال ال 24 الساعه الاخيره هناك ثمانيه
شهداء من بينهم ثلاثه تم اغتيالهم بشكل
وبدم بارد داخل مستشفى ابن سينا صباح هذا
اليوم في من قبل قوات احتلال التي تسلل
جنودها متسترين ومتخفيش المدني زي الاطباء
وزي ممرضين وزي نساء وكذلك
بازياء لمواطنين عاديين وقد تسللوا فراده
وليس كمجموعه واحده نعم وتم استخدام حتى
مسدسات كاتمه للصوت مثل ما ذكر من معلومات
ابقى معنا وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره
في رام الله